Alice:我们要车才能去吗
Alice: Do we need a car to go there?
Katrina: 必须要现在去啊
Katrina: We need to go right now.
Alice:就是行
Alice: Okay, sure.
Katrina: 吧我的咖啡拿下来
Katrina: Bring my coffee down.
Tasha:  那我们那我们摊个饼吧就
Tasha: Then let's make some pancakes.
Jake:摊可以摊
Jake: Sure, we can make them.
Katrina:  都行
Katrina: Anything is fine.
Katrina:  这草莓我要种的
Katrina: I want to plant this strawberry.
Alice:咖啡在这个
Alice: The coffee is here.
Katrina:  ok
Katrina: Okay.
Tasha:  你觉得这么多够了吗
Tasha: Do you think this much is enough?
Katrina:  我把这个放窗台上正好
Katrina: I'll put this on the windowsill, it's perfect.
Alice:嗯能做
Alice: Yeah, that works.
Jake:是刚到的吗
Jake: Did it just arrive?
Jake: 这是你带来的
Jake: Did you bring this?
Alice: 2个
Alice: Two of them.
Katrina:  不是这是那天海底捞送的
Katrina: No, Haidilao delivered it the other day.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Katrina:  我刚刚看到我有个阳台我把这个种下来
Katrina: I just saw I have a balcony, so I'll plant it there.
Jake: 带资进组
Jake: Funded the group project.
Tasha:  那就这么多吧也不用做很多我觉得
Tasha: This much should be enough, we don't need to make a lot, I think.
Katrina:  这是啥呀
Katrina: What's this?
Tasha:  毕竟中午还要吃饭
Tasha: After all, we still have lunch.
Tasha:  我就倒一一3个4个就行
Tasha: I'll just pour three or four, that's enough.
Tasha: 因为
Tasha: Because...
Alice:够吗
Alice: Is it enough?
Tasha:  再再倒一些
Tasha: Pour a bit more.
Lucia: sorry按错键了
Lucia: Sorry, I pressed the wrong button.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 再来一次
Lucia: Let's try again.
Jake: 嗯嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Katrina:  这是什么意思呢
Katrina: What does this mean?
Tasha:  这好晒啊
Tasha: It's so sunny.
Alice:我来吧
Alice: Let me do it.
Jake: 先删掉吧
Jake: Just delete it first.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Jake: 没关系挺好
Jake: It's okay, no big deal.
Tasha:  就这样调面糊吧
Tasha: Just mix the batter like this.
Tasha:  哈哈我们家就这样调然后直接开摊
Tasha: Haha, at our place, we mix it like this and start making pancakes right away.
Jake: 多按了俩键问题不大
Jake: Pressed two extra buttons, it's not a big problem.
Katrina:  赠品樱桃萝卜种子
Katrina: Free cherry radish seeds.
Alice: 因为我一般用的是筷子
Alice: Because I usually use chopsticks.
Tasha:  oh
Tasha: Oh.
Alice: 有用过这个
Alice: Have you used this?
Katrina:  先种两个吗
Katrina: Should we plant two first?
Tasha:  接瓶水
Tasha: Get a bottle of water.
Tasha:  我觉得应该到矿泉水
Tasha: I think we should use mineral water.
Lucia: 呃我时间是写10
Lucia: Uh, my time is written as 10.
Alice: 我们应该放在那个大一点的面盆里
Alice: We should put it in a bigger basin.
Jake: 好的43 没没关系
Jake: Okay, 43, no problem.
Tasha:  嗯这个里面我主要觉得有这个嘴好摊
Tasha: Hmm, I think this spout is easy to use.
Alice:你给我拿个筷子吧
Alice: Can you get me a pair of chopsticks?
Jake: 那你们俩聊聊舞蹈
Jake: Then you two talk about dancing.
Jake: 在冲完牛奶之后
Jake: After making the milk.
Tasha:  没事我来
Tasha: It's okay, I'll do it.
Katrina:  可以
Katrina: Sure.
Lucia: 可以我们可以选一下
Lucia: Okay, we can choose.
Jake: 哦对对然后你们可以在这比划比划
Jake: Oh right, then you can compare here.
Alice:这个
Alice: This one.
Katrina:  然后把草莓种了
Katrina: And then plant the strawberries.
Alice: 你们家里面鸡蛋饼是比较稀的
Alice: Are the egg pancakes in your house usually thin?
Jake: 因为相机都给你们布好了
Jake: Because the cameras are all set up for you.
Alice: 还是比较稠的
Alice: Or are they thicker?
Jake: 哈哈哈二楼相机没有布好
Jake: Haha, the second floor cameras aren't set up.
Tasha:  比较顺滑的
Tasha: They are smoother.
Jake: 所以没办法上去比划
Jake: So we can't go up to compare.
Lucia: 这里如果有美团的话地址
Lucia: If there's Meituan here, the address...
Alice: 你看不好弄
Alice: See, it's not easy to do.
Jake: 选地址是
Jake: The address selection is...
Jake: 玉河区30玉河区53号你可以直接对
Jake: Yuhe District, 30 Yuhe District, 53. You can go directly there.
Tasha:  筷子还得洗
Tasha: Chopsticks need to be washed too.
Alice: 你这个不也得洗吗
Alice: Doesn't this need to be washed as well?
Lucia: 50 53号
Lucia: 50, 53.
Alice: 给我吧
Alice: Give it to me.
Jake: 哦对就是把31改成53
Jake: Oh right, just change 31 to 53.
Jake: 因为31他找不到他要绕圈
Jake: Because he can't find 31, he has to circle around.
Lucia: 我的网络又开始不太给力
Lucia: My internet is starting to lag again.
Jake: 没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Katrina: 居然是这样我靠
Katrina: Is that so? Damn.
Lucia: 要买一个碘伏我的脚蹭破了
Lucia: I need to buy some iodine, I scraped my foot.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 那我可以问问这个管家
Jake: Then I can ask the housekeeper about it.
Alice: 我先帮你搅着吧
Alice: I'll help you stir it first.
Lucia: 如果他有的话
Lucia: If they have any.
Katrina:  这边他们是不打扫卫生是吗扔垃圾
Katrina: They don't clean up here, do they? Throwing out the trash.
Jake: 呃可以跟他们说他们就对
Jake: Uh, you can tell them and they will.
Lucia: 可以让他来打扫应该
Lucia: You should ask them to clean up.
Katrina: 哦可以让他们打扫
Katrina: Oh, we can ask them to clean.
Jake: 好
Jake: Sure.
Alice:太绸了
Alice: It's too sticky.
Lucia: 为什么转不出来呢
Lucia: Why can't it come out?
Tasha:  嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake: 哎对京东是你要让让
Jake: Hey, for JD.com, you need to let...
Jake: 你什么时候去
Jake: When are you going?
Tasha:  下午他走了
Tasha: He left in the afternoon.
Jake: 嗯OK
Jake: Hmm, OK.
Katrina:  是不是就是昨天我们拿快递那个他说什么京东来了没
Katrina: Wasn't it yesterday when we picked up the package that they said JD.com was here?
Tasha:  嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Katrina:  他不是固定的
Katrina: He's not fixed.
Tasha:  感觉这个村
Tasha: Feels like this village...
Lucia: 这和我连VPN有关系吗
Lucia: Does this have anything to do with me connecting to a VPN?
Katrina:  就是外来人员
Katrina: Just outsiders.
Lucia: 但是我看对
Lucia: But I see...
Katrina:  随时来探望我们一下
Katrina: They come visit us anytime.
Jake: 卡住了是吗
Jake: It's stuck, right?
Lucia: 我看我看
Lucia: Let me see, let me see.
Jake: 应该没有什么
Jake: There shouldn't be any problem.
Lucia: 您好像能正确使用美团
Lucia: You seem to use Meituan correctly.
Lucia: 我觉得应该不是这个原因
Lucia: I don't think that's the reason.
Tasha:  啊没关系
Tasha: Ah, it's okay.
Jake: 对美团的问题
Jake: It's a Meituan issue.
Katrina:  拿个小杯子
Katrina: Get a small cup.
Tasha:  no not at all
Tasha: No, not at all.
Lucia: 我退出来重新进一下
Lucia: I'll exit and re-enter.
Jake: 这是那次海底捞的视频
Jake: This is the video from Haidilao that time.
Tasha:  还会再稀一点
Tasha: It will get thinner.
Tasha:  面水加多了加面面加多了加水
Tasha: Add more water to the noodles, if you add too much, add more noodles, if you add too much water...
Alice:是这样的
Alice: It's like that.
Katrina:  先要在热水里泡5分钟
Katrina: First, soak it in hot water for 5 minutes.
Jake: 这么多种子
Jake: So many seeds
Jake: 他要种什么东西
Jake: What is he going to plant?
Katrina:  没有这应该是土吧
Katrina: No, this should be soil
Katrina:  这是草莓
Katrina: These are strawberries
Katrina:  这是赠送的樱桃萝卜
Katrina: These are cherry radishes as a gift
Jake: 啊还能种樱桃
Jake: Ah, you can still plant cherries
Jake: 呵呵樱桃不是种很久吗
Jake: Haha, don't cherries take a long time to grow?
Katrina:  哈哈海底捞
Katrina: Haha, Haidilao
Katrina:  怎么海底捞的业务蛮广啊
Katrina: How come Haidilao's business is so broad?
Jake: 樱桃树你种过吗
Jake: Have you ever planted a cherry tree?
Katrina:  啊樱桃不是树吗
Katrina: Ah, aren't cherries from a tree?
Tasha:  吃过算吗
Tasha: Does eating them count?
Katrina:  他怎么能给我种呢
Katrina: How can he plant them for me?
Jake: 呵呵呵吃过差不多
Jake: Haha, eating them is almost the same
Katrina:  热水
Katrina: Hot water
Alice: 你要的稠度吗
Alice: Is this the consistency you want?
Tasha:  还要再稀一点
Tasha: It needs to be a bit thinner
Alice: 那你得放水
Alice: Then you need to add water
Jake: 点上了吗
Jake: Did you light it?
Alice: 你就放这一点
Alice: You just add this bit
Lucia: nope定位飘到外星球去了
Lucia: Nope, the location marker drifted to outer space
Tasha:  我又怕放多了
Tasha: I'm afraid of adding too much
Jake: 我帮你点
Jake: I'll help you light it
Alice: 没事我来了我就有点费劲
Alice: It's okay, I'm here, it's just a bit tricky
Lucia: 奇怪啊
Lucia: Strange
Katrina:  烧壶热水
Katrina: Boil a pot of hot water
Jake: 你用的是美团外卖是吧
Jake: You're using Meituan delivery, right?
Lucia: 对就我直接点了美团的APP然后它里面会有这个
Lucia: Yes, I just ordered through the Meituan app and it should have it
Lucia: 刚才里面已经搞好了但是它突然又不对了
Lucia: It was fine just now, but then it suddenly went wrong
Tasha:  我在想要不要那个搅拌器
Tasha: I'm thinking if we need a mixer
Lucia: 51号是吗
Lucia: Number 51, right?
Tasha:  会不会搅拌的更顺一点
Tasha: Wouldn't it blend more smoothly?
Jake:  53
Jake: 53
Lucia: 53 嗯
Lucia: 53, hmm
Tasha:  感觉有颗粒感
Tasha: Feels a bit grainy
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Lucia: 我是输入53吗
Lucia: Should I input 53?
Alice: 你不是要弄更多吗
Alice: Don't you want to add more?
Lucia: 因为我看他那里还有一个
Lucia: Because I saw there's another one
Lucia: 就是就算你输入
Lucia: Even if you input
Lucia: 他要你选定位还是什么的
Lucia: Does he want you to choose a location or something?
Jake: 您直接输就好了
Jake: You can just input it directly.
Tasha:  他最后就是滑起来没有阻力的那种
Tasha: In the end, it slides smoothly without any resistance.
Tasha:  你懂我的状态吗
Tasha: Do you understand my situation?
Alice: 其实
Alice: Actually...
Lucia: 为什么你的可以正常使用呢
Lucia: Why can yours be used normally?
Alice: 蛋液应该后放
Alice: The egg mixture should be added last.
Alice: 因为蛋液一放进去
Alice: Because once you add the egg mixture,
Alice: 他把那个面给裹住了
Alice: it coats the dough.
Lucia: 哦我看一下您这个
Lucia: Oh, let me take a look at yours.
Jake: 我不知道美团有可能也有用
Jake: I don't know, maybe Meituan can be used too.
Alice: 没关系早饭而已
Alice: It's just breakfast, no worries.
Lucia: 里面
Lucia: Inside...
Lucia: 你的APP名字就叫美团外卖
Lucia: Your app is called Meituan Waimai.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 我再下个APP我
Lucia: I'll download another app then.
Katrina:  舞蹈我来看一下
Katrina: Let me check out the dance.
Katrina:  刚刚把平板带下来
Katrina: Just brought the tablet down.
Alice: 是你要的是再稀一点还是
Alice: Do you want it a bit more runny or...
Tasha:  我靠怎么这么稠真的是用低筋面粉吗
Tasha: Oh my, why is it so thick? Are you sure this is cake flour?
Tasha:  我怎么记得是用糯米粉
Tasha: I remember it should be glutinous rice flour.
Alice:什么 糯米粉
Alice: What? Glutinous rice flour?
Katrina:  那我们跳舞是不是还要带上修硕一起
Katrina: Shouldn't we include Shure when we dance?
Lucia: 我也在想
Lucia: I was thinking the same.
Lucia: 至少我们练的时候要大家要带上
Lucia: At least when we practice, everyone should be there.
Tasha:  因为感觉这种有点起劲的感觉
Tasha: Because it feels more energetic this way.
Lucia: 那会很影响
Lucia: That would be very disruptive.
Katrina:  晚上再教他也没事
Katrina: It's okay to teach him in the evening.
Lucia: 会影响一些动作
Lucia: It might mess up some moves.
Katrina:  不是如果是有男生加入的话
Katrina: No, if a guy joins, then the dance style can't be too...
Alice: 这是低筋面粉
Alice: This is cake flour.
Katrina:  那个舞蹈风格就不能选那个太
Katrina: The dance style shouldn't be too...
Alice: 关系都是面
Alice: Anyway, it's all flour.
Katrina:  就选那种
Katrina: Just choose the one...
Jake: 你可以不加入
Jake: You can choose not to join,
Jake: 也可以加入都是你们说了算
Jake: or you can join, it's up to you guys.
Lucia: 要不就加入吧
Lucia: How about we let him join?
Katrina:  啊啊
Katrina: Ah, okay.
Lucia: 让人多一点
Lucia: The more, the merrier.
Katrina:  来吧一起社死吧
Katrina: Let's all socially die together.
Lucia: 显得有气势一些显得有
Lucia: It makes it look more impressive, makes it look more...
Katrina:  我找找
Katrina: Let me find it.
Katrina:  我问问我同学他们之前跳过什么
Katrina: I'll ask my classmates what they danced to before.
Tasha:  天呐感觉很失败哈哈哈
Tasha: Oh my god, this feels like a failure, haha.
Alice: 你放调料了吗
Alice: Did you add the seasoning?
Tasha:  没有不是加糖吗
Tasha: No, isn't it supposed to be sugar?
Lucia: 但我觉得我这次穿来的衣服里面
Lucia: But I think out of all the clothes I brought this time...
Alice: 没加呢我不会做甜的
Alice: I haven't added it yet. I can't make sweet stuff.
Lucia: 最适合的可能就是这条
Lucia: The most suitable might be these.
Lucia: 这条裤子和那个白色上衣了
Lucia: These pants and that white top.
Tasha:  嗯我们是蘸也可以直接现在加
Tasha: Hmm, we can dip it or add it directly now.
Katrina:  都行
Katrina: Both ways work.
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So...
Lucia: 我们也可以不那么统一
Lucia: We don't have to be that uniform.
Alice: 哎等一下这个是你想要的稠度吗
Alice: Hey, wait a minute. Is this the thickness you want?
Tasha:  啊
Tasha: Huh?
Lucia: 就是服装风格差不多就可以了
Lucia: As long as the style is similar, it's fine.
Tasha:  可以吧差不多就这样吧
Tasha: Okay, this should be fine.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 你放糖进去
Alice: Did you add sugar?
Jake: 或者自己做
Jake: Or make it yourself.
Alice: 直接这样放糖它会不会不融化呀
Alice: If you add sugar like this, won't it not dissolve?
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 节省一些预算
Lucia: Save some budget.
Tasha:  好吧那就这样吧
Tasha: Alright, let's do it this way then.
Katrina:  直接穿那种纸质的衣服
Katrina: Just wear those paper outfits.
Lucia: 我们的杯子在那边OK
Lucia: Our cups are over there, okay.
Katrina:  哎这好苦
Katrina: Ugh, this is so bitter.
Jake: 也也不一定
Jake: Not necessarily.
Jake: 自己做不一定节省预预算
Jake: Making it yourself doesn't necessarily save budget.
Lucia: 是吗
Lucia: Really?
Katrina:  我加了他倒进来就这么多
Katrina: I added it, and he poured this much.
Katrina:  然后我加了这么多牛奶还是很苦
Katrina: Then I added this much milk, and it's still bitter.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Lucia: 那都有谁喝咖啡啊
Lucia: So who drinks coffee?
Lucia: 我统计一下
Lucia: I'll take a count.
Katrina:  我已经喝了一杯
Katrina: I already had a cup.
Katrina:  这是我的
Katrina: This one is mine.
Lucia: 不喝咖啡的啊
Lucia: Who doesn't drink coffee?
Alice: 我来一个吧
Alice: I'll have one.
Lucia: 你喝吗
Lucia: Are you drinking?
Jake: 来喝我也喝
Jake: Sure, I'll drink too.
Alice: 算了我不来了
Alice: Never mind, I'm not coming.
Tasha:  我要喝牛奶
Tasha: I want milk.
Lucia: 呃要咖里面要不要咖啡您算上了
Lucia: Uh, do you want coffee in your coffee?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 雨轩还喝咖啡吗不喝
Lucia: Does Yuxuan still drink coffee? No?
Katrina:  我不喝
Katrina: I don't drink.
Katrina:  这密Wifi密码
Katrina: This Wifi password...
Jake: 哎呀挡住了挡住了挡住了
Jake: Oh no, it's blocked, it's blocked.
Lucia: 那现在就两个人OK
Lucia: So now there are only two people, okay.
Jake: 对也挡住了
Jake: Yeah, it's blocked.
Katrina:  Wifi密码是多少来着
Katrina: What's the Wifi password again?
Jake: 这儿
Jake: Here.
Katrina:  哦哦
Katrina: Oh, okay.
Alice: 我来一个吧
Alice: I'll have one.
Jake: 怎么还有指纹呢
Jake: Why is there a fingerprint?
Tasha:  来一个什么
Tasha: Have what?
Katrina:  谁偷偷擦
Katrina: Who secretly wiped it?
Alice: 喝的
Alice: A drink.
Tasha:  你刚刚不是报名了咖啡吗
Tasha: Didn't you just sign up for coffee?
Alice: 对啊但是我又取消了
Alice: Yeah, but I canceled it.
Alice: 我现在报一下
Alice: I'm signing up now.
Lucia: 啊那你重新报名
Lucia: Ah, then you need to sign up again.
Lucia: 哈哈我们的咖啡名额减少到一个
Lucia: Haha, our coffee quota is down to one.
Alice: 刚刚已经把我算上了总共才两个
Alice: They already counted me, so there are only two in total.
Lucia: 对对因为我我我现在不是特别困
Lucia: Right, because I'm not really sleepy right now.
Lucia: 所以我先不喝
Lucia: So, I'm not drinking.
Alice: OK我只是想有个味道
Alice: Okay, I just want the taste.
Lucia: 然后雨轩刚已经喝过了
Lucia: And Yuxuan already had some.
Lucia: 那你喝什么呢
Lucia: So what are you having?
Alice: 咖啡吧
Alice: Coffee.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 哎呀哈哈
Lucia: Oh my, haha.
Lucia: 对方撤出撤回了一条消息又发送了
Lucia: The other party withdrew a message and then sent it again.
Lucia: 一样的是吧
Lucia: Is it the same one?
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 剩下的人都喝牛奶吗
Lucia: Is everyone else just drinking milk?
Lucia: 嗯找一个小锅什么的
Lucia: Hmm, let's find a small pot or something.
Jake: 路亚是买好了吗
Jake: Did you buy the lure?
Tasha:  感觉水有点多
Tasha: Feels like there's too much water.
Lucia: 啊什么啊还没呢
Lucia: Ah, what? Not yet.
Jake: 买好还买
Jake: Buy more if you did.
Jake: 那我先放在
Jake: I'll just put it here.
Jake: 或者我联系一下修硕
Jake: Or I could contact Shure.
Jake: 哎先联系一下收垃圾
Jake: Hey, let's contact the garbage collector first.
Lucia: 或许可以问一下他们
Lucia: Maybe we can ask them.
Lucia: 就是民宿这边有没有碘伏或者酒精
Lucia: If the guesthouse has any iodine or alcohol.
Tasha:  害怕
Tasha: I'm scared.
Jake: 嗯嗯好
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Alice: 都是食物我能做做不了
Alice: It's all food, I can do it, but I can't.
Lucia: 因为我我刚刷了一下
Lucia: Because I just refreshed it.
Lucia: 他还没有刷新出来
Lucia: It hasn't refreshed yet.
Katrina:  你们听过这个歌吗
Katrina: Have you guys heard this song?
Katrina:  就这个舞很简单
Katrina: This dance is really simple.
Lucia: 我好像听过让我看一眼
Lucia: I think I've heard it, let me see.
Tasha:  再加点面粉吧哈哈
Tasha: Add more flour, haha.
Katrina:  非常简单
Katrina: Very simple.
Katrina:  就是人家跳年会的舞
Katrina: It's the kind of dance people do at annual parties.
Katrina:  这是我们之前艺术团跳过跳着玩的
Katrina: Our art troupe used to do it for fun.
Lucia: 这个是一个抖音上很火的曲子吗
Lucia: Is this a popular song on TikTok?
Katrina: 好像是
Katrina: Seems like it.
Lucia: 觉得我好像在哪里听过
Lucia: I think I've heard it somewhere.
Jake: 这是一个经典的一个
Jake: It's a classic.
Katrina:  非常经典的
Katrina: Very classic.
Alice: 帮你搅吧就有点费力费手
Alice: Need help stirring? It's a bit hard on the hands.
Jake: 这这是哪年
Jake: What year is this from?
Jake: 零几年的歌还是八几年的歌呀
Jake: Is it a song from the 2000s or the 80s?
Katrina:  嗯呵
Katrina: Hmm, haha.
Katrina:  失恋阵线联盟
Katrina: "Alliance of the Heartbroken."
Jake: 这可能是八几年的歌
Jake: It might be from the 80s.
Katrina:  这倒是很简单
Katrina: This is really simple.
Lucia: 哎对这个
Lucia: Yeah, this one.
Tasha:  我发给他了吗
Tasha: Did I send it to him?
Lucia: 这个还蛮简单的
Lucia: This one's quite simple.
Katrina:  就当时我们艺术团
Katrina: Back then, our art troupe...
Katrina:  男生可以跳的
Katrina: Even the guys could do it.
Katrina:  多长时间
Katrina: How long is it?
Katrina:  2分42 跳个2分钟差不多
Katrina: 2 minutes and 42 seconds. Jump for about 2 minutes.
Katrina:  就跳个1分钟就可以了
Katrina: Just jump for 1 minute, that's enough.
Katrina:  而且动作幅度也不大
Katrina: And the movements aren't that big.
Lucia: 而且动作幅度也不大
Lucia: And the movements aren't that big.
Lucia: 其实整体来说戴个眼镜也没什么怪
Lucia: Actually, wearing glasses doesn't look weird at all.
Lucia: 你看他们也戴着呢哈哈哈
Lucia: Look, they're wearing them too, hahaha.
Katrina:  哎对哦
Katrina: Oh, right.
Alice: 薇薇好了
Alice: Tasha is ready.
Katrina:  我们可以搞一点造型
Katrina: We can create some styles.
Katrina:  cos一棵树哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Like cosplay a tree, hahaha.
Alice: 可以吗可以
Alice: Can we? Sure.
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Ahahaha.
Lucia: 一棵树动作幅度这么大吗
Lucia: Does a tree need such big movements?
Katrina:  搞一个那个树的头套
Katrina: Get a tree headpiece.
Katrina:  加入备选吧
Katrina: Let's add it to the options.
Tasha:  那个铜锣烧是不是用低筋面粉
Tasha: Is dorayaki made with cake flour?
Lucia: 他现在加载出来了
Lucia: It's loading now.
Alice: 铜锣烧
Alice: Dorayaki.
Katrina:  哦还有个你你你跳舞吗
Katrina: Oh, do you dance?
Katrina:  这不是修硕最爱的摇滚吗
Katrina: Isn't this Shure's favorite rock music?
Tasha:  糯米粉好吧
Tasha: Okay, glutinous rice flour then.
Tasha:  算了不学了
Tasha: Nevermind, I won't learn it.
Katrina:  这也可以
Katrina: This works too.
Katrina:  这也可以当我们毕设开头
Katrina: This can be the opening of our final project.
Tasha:  啊我想要换个容器
Tasha: Ah, I want to change the container.
Lucia: 为什么这个
Lucia: Why this one?
Jake: 你们
Jake: You guys...
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Lucia: 看起来有一点哈哈
Lucia: It looks kind of funny, haha.
Katrina:  哎呦这还有一点什么元素呢
Katrina: Oh, there's some element to it.
Jake: 你你你们想要打扫房间吗
Jake: Do you guys want to clean the room?
Tasha:  呃我只是想过筛一下
Tasha: Uh, I just want to sift it.
Katrina:  嗯行
Katrina: Hmm, okay.
Jake: 打房OK行
Jake: Cleaning is okay.
Katrina:  还有换队形
Katrina: And change formations.
Lucia: 是我们要现在收拾一下扫描吗
Lucia: Should we tidy up now?
Alice: 这个稠度不好过筛
Alice: This consistency is hard to sift.
Jake: 呃也不是
Jake: Not really.
Jake: 就是可以换
Jake: But you can change it.
Katrina:  哎这好看
Katrina: Oh, this looks nice.
Jake: 可以这个哎
Jake: Okay, this one is good.
Katrina:  这比刚刚那好看
Katrina: This looks better than the previous one.
Alice: 呃那你试试吧
Alice: Uh, then you try it.
Jake: 也可以啊
Jake: That works too.
Katrina:  这还有点hip Hop元素
Katrina: This one has a bit of hip hop elements.
Jake: 晚上我们也不是晚上
Jake: Tonight, or rather not tonight...
Tasha:  因为感觉里面有颗粒
Tasha: Because it feels like there are particles inside.
Jake: 可能下午我们就扫一下
Jake: Maybe in the afternoon we'll clean it up.
Jake: 他们先帮你们扫一下
Jake: They will help you clean it first.
Jake: 你们再整理一下应该就好对
Jake: Then you can tidy up a bit more, that should be good.
Tasha:  但这个这个网确实太密了
Tasha: But this net is really too dense.
Lucia: 哦也可以
Lucia: Oh, that's fine.
Tasha:  哇像芝士
Tasha: Wow, like cheese.
Tasha:  完了
Tasha: Oh no.
Tasha:  买的网太密了
Tasha: The net we bought is too dense.
Tasha:  我靠
Tasha: Oh crap.
Tasha:  玛莎卡
Tasha: Mashaka.
Alice: 我之前做章鱼小丸子的时候试过过筛
Alice: When I made takoyaki before, I tried sifting it.
Katrina:  这这怎么又是SOLO
Katrina: Why does this turn into a solo again?
Alice: 确实不好过筛
Alice: It's really hard to sift.
Katrina:  这咱就奇怪了
Katrina: This is really strange.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia: 我们可以把那个男生的站位给他删掉
Lucia: We can just remove the guy's spot.
Lucia: 反正我们也没那么多人
Lucia: Anyway, we don't have that many people.
Tasha:  稍等我一下
Tasha: Wait a moment.
Katrina:  哎我想一下有个什么舞来着
Katrina: Hey, I'm trying to remember a dance...
Katrina:  追求完美的
Katrina: Pursuing perfection.
Katrina:  偶像万万岁哦
Katrina: Long live idols.
Katrina:  高中的一个舞这也还行2分钟感觉两天时间
Katrina: A high school dance, this one is okay too. Two minutes feels like two days.
Alice: 真的熟了之后没啥区别
Alice: Once you get familiar with it, there's no difference.
Katrina:  还有女团舞
Katrina: There's also girl group dances.
Katrina:  哈哈哈先开始
Katrina: Hahaha, let's start.
Katrina:  收藏一下吧
Katrina: Let's save it.
Katrina:  嗯还有那个偶像 万万岁
Katrina: And there's that "Long live idols."
Alice: 因为我之前做章鱼小丸子时候过筛
Alice: When I made takoyaki before, I sifted it.
Katrina:  是要搞嗨一点的歌
Katrina: We need a more upbeat song.
Alice: 他不是更细
Alice: Isn't it finer?
Tasha: 更细腻 对
Tasha: More delicate, yes.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  才好玩
Katrina: That's more fun.
Jake: 买的吗就是
Jake: Did you buy it?
Alice: 但是就是我那时候
Alice: But at that time...
Alice: 就是跟这种稠度差不多的那个
Alice: It was about the same consistency as this.
Lucia: 出大门左转
Lucia: Go out the main door and turn left.
Alice: 过筛真是艰难的要死
Alice: Sifting it was incredibly difficult.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Got it.
Tasha:  巨难过筛
Tasha: Sifting it was super hard.
Lucia: 啊他没有碘伏是吧
Lucia: Ah, he doesn't have iodine, right?
Lucia: 那我就在美团订一个
Lucia: Then I'll order one on Meituan.
Alice: 这样吧没关系
Alice: It's okay, no worries.
Tasha:  好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Jake: 嗯哦哦OK
Jake: Hmm, oh, okay.
Lucia: 刚才已经找好了
Lucia: I've already found it.
Katrina:  还有我的未来事业
Katrina: And my future career.
Tasha:  OK上锅
Tasha: Okay, into the pot.
Lucia: 53号楼OK
Lucia: Building 53, okay.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha:  铲子
Tasha: Spatula.
Katrina:  好像广播体操
Katrina: It feels like a broadcast exercise.
Tasha:  我靠这铲子怎么这么油
Tasha: Gosh, why is this spatula so oily?
Tasha:  受不了了好黏糊
Tasha: I can't stand it, it's so sticky.
Lucia: 隐私保护中
Lucia: Privacy protection in progress.
Alice:我喝凉的就行
Alice: I'll just have it cold.
Lucia: 完全像这样
Lucia: Just like this, totally.
Alice: 不用给我弄热的
Alice: No need to heat it for me.
Lucia: 呃没事反正牛奶会变成热的
Lucia: Uh, it's fine, the milk will get hot anyway.
Lucia: 所以你也可以加热牛奶
Lucia: So you can heat the milk if you want.
Lucia: 万一你in case you change your mind
Lucia: In case you change your mind.
Alice: 噢不不不哈哈
Alice: Oh no no no, haha.
Alice: 不不不不
Alice: No, no, no, no, no.
Jake: 哈哈哈有了一手啊
Jake: Haha, got a trick up your sleeve.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha:  什么
Tasha: What?
Alice: no no no no no
Alice: No, no, no, no, no.
Alice: 我不喝我不喝热的
Alice: I don't drink hot milk.
Jake: 哈哈哈有了一手
Jake: Haha, got a trick up your sleeve.
Alice: 牛奶我喝凉的就行了啊
Alice: I'll just drink cold milk, okay?
Tasha:  啊不要放在这里
Tasha: Ah, don't put it here.
Alice: 不要放在这里啊
Alice: Don't put it here, okay?
Lucia: 不我不我不放
Lucia: No, I won't, I won't.
Alice: 不不放
Alice: No, no, don't put it
Lucia: 我啊你你的意思是你要用这个锅是吗
Lucia: I... you mean you want to use this pot, right?
Tasha:  哦
Tasha: Oh
Lucia: 啊没有没有我不用这个锅
Lucia: Ah, no, no, I'm not using this pot
Lucia: 我只是把这个在这里放一下
Lucia: I'm just putting this here for a moment
Lucia: 然后找一个锅给它倒进去而已
Lucia: Then I'll find another pot to pour it into
Lucia: 他这里有没有那种专门的牛奶壶
Lucia: Is there a special milk jug here?
Lucia: 感觉好像没有什么呃
Lucia: It seems like there's none, um
Alice: 应该不会有
Alice: There probably isn't
Lucia: 因为如果没有的话
Lucia: Because if there isn't
Lucia: 那个那个锅用来热牛奶就太大了
Lucia: That pot would be too big to heat milk
Lucia: 感觉一个热进去才能把他
Lucia: It feels like heating just a bit can
Alice: 我洗个杯子吧
Alice: I'll wash a cup
Alice: 我不喝热的
Alice: I don't drink it hot
Lucia: 才能把他盖到底的感觉
Lucia: It feels like it can cover the bottom
Alice: 我们都是用这种杯子是吗
Alice: Are we all using these cups?
Lucia: 好像只有
Lucia: It seems like
Lucia: 这种杯子耶
Lucia: It's just these cups
Alice: 哦对好的
Alice: Oh, right, okay
Alice: 那我洗一个吧
Alice: Then I'll wash one
Lucia: 但是你也可以用碗
Lucia: But you can also use a bowl
Tasha:  怎么办第一次用这种锅
Tasha: What should I do, first time using this pot
Alice: 好给外国人一点震撼
Alice: Sure, give foreigners a surprise
Lucia: 我觉这个锅用来热牛奶也太
Lucia: I think this pot is too
Lucia: 哈哈也太
Lucia: Haha, too
Lucia: 但是好像没有别的锅了
Lucia: But it seems like there's no other pot
Alice: 放油了吗
Alice: Did you add oil?
Tasha:  放了
Tasha: Yes
Lucia: 要不就暂且用这个吧
Lucia: Let's just use this for now
Tasha:  我没有用过这个锅煎饼
Tasha: I've never used this pot to make pancakes
Alice: 啊这这油有点多
Alice: Ah, the oil is a bit much
Tasha:  有点多是吧哈哈
Tasha: A bit much, right? Haha
Alice: 就这样我我
Alice: Just like this, I...
Tasha:  那倒出来一些吧
Tasha: Then pour some out
Alice: 你你没地方倒吧
Alice: You don't have anywhere to pour it, right?
Alice: 你就那样吧
Alice: Just leave it like that
Alice: 留在锅里一点也没事
Alice: Leaving a bit in the pot is fine
Alice: 抽油烟机抽油烟机
Alice: Turn on the range hood
Tasha:  啊好好好熏呀
Tasha: Ah, okay okay, it's really smoky
Alice: 别闻这个味
Alice: Don't smell this
Alice: 这个味太
Alice: This flavor is too...
Alice: 火还可以
Alice: The heat is okay.
Alice: 小心一点
Alice: Be careful.